[Music]  what should they do from here in terms  of trying to make ver relationship now  be a healthy relationship in the wake of  everything they should not do any  interviews it's all right you have to  relive it over and over yes people are  gonna be talking about this for mmm well  how long has been since Jason could  people still talk about that yeah  Jason's probably like oh but yeah I  would say just go to therapy  okay dead serious do you Saunders  therapy oh yeah yeah yeah we I think the  show should actually give a therapist  for the couples who come out of it  because it's so great I'm like Protheroe  great yeah everybody needs good mental  health and sometimes you need that third  perk and I do think that they could  probably use that after going through  what they have also yeah stay out of I  mean don't read things yeah go turn off  your comments on its ground go to an  island yeah yeah  because it's gonna be rough